is customary to address me as your
majesty so get your knees on the ground
i'm royalty hello brooklyn heights or
should i say
your majesty
[Laughter]
hi baby how are you i am so good i am
even
better with queen of the north in my
life
i've done the race i've got this far
look to the north cause i'm the star
gonna make your body move just like
abita
might be nice but i'm a diva
congratulations on this
i have to say we had this conversation
before where i was like
would you ever do music and you were
like hell no
um why the change of heart i was very
adamant that i would not do music i'm
pretty sure i've been quoted on that too
i recorded this song right after we
wrapped filming season one of canada's
drag race and then of course cove it
happened
so like it got put on the back burner
and everything kind of shut down we're
all just craving content right now yeah
we all just want something to watch and
something cool
and then i came up with this concept for
the video and i was like this is what i
want to do
and then that's kind of when i started
to get excited about it
then we got priyanka on the track and
she was able to record it
remotely and it just really all came
together and i was like oh this is
fantastic
of course priyanka is the winner of
season one of canada's drag race you two
are great friends i love
pre what do you think she added to this
track
oh she added her own little brand of
chaos
to chaos that's that's how i always
describe priyanka she's chaotic
she got an upgrade 2.0 taking her crown
international
one glued that lace front watch out
check out the barking
we really balance each other well
because we're very fire and ice like i'm
more cool kind of collected and she's
very like
you dedicated this to bianca del rio was
bianca like
girl do not do music and this was your
way of being like
look at me now [ __ ] or was she actually
supportive about it
miyaga's a great friend um but she's no
she was always very like queen don't do
it
don't don't do music she was she was she
always like i told her
she was like oh god you're not she
couldn't believe it
so now that you've dipped your toes into
this music world
do you think of maybe a full-length
album in the future or are you
just going to let the single breathe and
see what happens i'm definitely going to
let it breathe there are no plans to do
an album
currently i think i'd like i might do
another like song like maybe i'll
release one a year or something like
that there are queens out there who are
like legitimate recording artists and
who are musicians and singers and
are very talented i'm not one of those
people like this is like a fun
drag queen song canada's drag race was
such a fresh take on this
format he will be back for season two
along with stacey mckenzie
congratulations
on that how excited are you to get back
on set and introduce a whole new crop of
canadian drag performers to the world
girl i can't even tell you i'm ready to
start my engines
i still really can't believe it's real
it was so
good and i i'm a fan i'm a fan girl now
like that's
what it is it was it really was it was
so good
i think what made it so wonderful is
that no one really had an edit button on
them i think i feel like a lot of times
now with drag race the queens come on
just knowing how insane our fan base can
be they come on and they're
almost kind of scared to do anything or
say anything because they're scared to
get attacked online for it later
but these girls did not have that there
was no filter everyone was just
really 100 themselves and i think that's
what made the show so amazing
that's my biggest hope for season two is
that they just continue with that
authenticity that they brought to season
one
jeffrey is not back we heard for season
two
what are you gonna miss most about
having jeffrey on set and sitting beside
him at the judges panel
oh my gosh so much uh yeah we are really
going to miss him i think what i'm gonna
miss
most is his just he he brought wonderful
energy like he was such a ray of light
and i don't think a lot of people got to
see that but like he he was like the
most positive bubbly
enthusiastic person he loves drag so
much and he is such a fan of it the
thing i'm going to miss most is his
passion and his enthusiasm
for the art form and for the show at
just a point i really want to drive home
to everyone because i see it online
sometimes saying oh like
we won like he's not coming back like it
had nothing to do with the negativity he
faced he handled that so beautifully and
so professionally and like a champ and
he
was genuinely excited to come back and
really boil down to a scheduling
conflict
are you watching season 13 of drag race
right now i need brooklyn's take i feel
like you are
leaning towards rose
i am i am watching it yeah they're what
a great crop
every year and just they keep getting
better and better and they're
everyone's just so like put together now
i wouldn't mind if rose one i love
simone i love
i love candy too i love the i love the
the like she she really
brings a lot to the season like it would
not be she's kind of like the silky for
me like she just brings that
that craziness and she's just hysterical
and
yeah so i'm i'm i'm really enjoying it
brooke congrats on queen of the north it
is fantastic
i hope that there will be more singles
and videos in the future
i can't wait for season two of canada's
drag race and you know i love you i love
catching up with you all the time i love
you too hopefully we can do it in person
next time
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos